Hello everybody, my name is Markiplier,
and I hope you're doing very well today.
You're looking lovely, I love the way you look!
You got a new look and I like that.
New year, new you! Aaaaah...
I always find that slogan annoying because
you don't get a new you the day it turns to a new year.
New you takes a lot of hard work, a-and
that's kind of a discipline thing that I'm committing myself to this year.
I talked about this is in the sixteen million video but,
uh, this year I've been doing a ton of self improvement stuff, I've been
exercising the first thing I do when I wake up.
I wake up at 7:20am, and then I go work out for an hour,
and then I take a shower, and then I practice guitar for an hour,
and then I learn German for an hour, and then throughout the day
whenever I feel like it, and then I record for about four hours straight and that's every single day.
What I'm- what I'm trying to get at is that you can't have a new you instantly.
You can't just automatically do a new you.
You can't wake up one day and say, like,
"I'M DIFFERENT AS OF TODAY AND EVERYONE'S GONNA RECOGNIZE HOW DIFFERENT AND GREAT I'VE BECOME!"
It's still a lot of work. Motivation is one thing, and I said this on, uh,
on Facebook and Instagram when I was doing my sweat updates, uh, in the morning,
um, but I said motivation is one thing, but motivation is temporary. Motivation is like a feeling you get that fades away.
The only way to really get change is to commit yourself to discipline. To discipline yourself is to commit to something and make it a habit,
and hold yourself accountable for those changes on a day to day basis.
Doing the same thing every day becomes a habit, but it's harder and harder as time goes on,
because your body resists change. And it doesn't wanna change, it's comfortable where it is, so you have to
hold yourself accountable, and that's where discipline overtakes motivation in a lot of ways.
And that's kinda what I'm holding myself to this year.
I'm not even trying to, like, shove it in people's faces that,
"Hey, look at me, new year, new me! I'm doing a great job at being amazing!"
*sarcastic* Which is usually what I do in all my videos,
but at least I'm not trying to do it for, uh, what I've been doing there.
But I just wanted to mention that it's been going very well,
considering that this is the first week that I've been back and I've been on this new schedule, it's been going very well for me.
But how in the hell am I gonna know if I'm gonna commit to it when it's only one week in?
But all things aside it is good to know that some things do not change with time.
And one of those things is Tyler.
Tyler is like the immovable object to the unstoppable force that is the universe.
He is an-[Mark begins to break into laughter] he is an ever-standing constant in the universe.
You could measure time off of that guy's anal behavior. [Mark has a chuckle]
Don't get me wrong, I love Tyler to death, I don't wanna- I'm not criticizing him in any way.
But he is- he is very particular and if he ever says something that you might think,
"Oh, do you mean this?", he goes, "No."
"I mean exactly what I said, and I will defend it to the death!"
Even after this video comes out he will not admit any sort of misdoing
in what he said.
So we were all having a little meeting,
we're talking about logging stuff and keeping notes,
and he said, "Oh, you know, yeah, we should arch-ive all of the stuff that we do".
Wh-what?
What?
"Yeah, yeah, arch-ive. You know."
"Oh, archive. It can be said either way, though."
Ohhohohoho no. No, Tyler.
It's archive. It's definitely archive.
*warning headphone users*
"NO!!"
"It's ar- it could be arch-ive!"
So, in typical Tyler fashion, he defended it to the death.
As is his want, he's allowed to do that,
just like we're allowed to question it.
Okay, so to settle the debate, because we're not normal humans, we're "'Millennials", apparently.
So Ethan took to Twitter to try to settle the debate, so we asked people to send video of you guys saying the word "archive".
And to myself, I thought, "How badly could it go? It's probably-"
"Archive."
Perfectly fine, thank you @Savnarae.
You're a wonderful human being.
But then OGchan comes by and...
"Ar-chay-vay."
"Arch-ive."
"Rech-rekive."
"Artichokes."
no, not that.
"Onions..."
"and..."
*Mark trying to hold it together*
"Mom."
"Subscribe."
So it just- it just, uh...
It just starts to go
downhill.
"Fuck."
*Mark loses it and laughs*
*inhale*
*More laughter*
"Archive."
Yes, perfectly acceptable, thank you.
"Mmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmm archive?"
*Oh no, Mark caught a bad case of LOL*
Thank you, EvieTheHuman.
"Archive."
Uh-huh.
"Arch-ee-vay."
[person filming] "No, I'm not ready!"
[person filming] "Okay."
"Arch-ee-vay."
*apparently this turned into a "Try Not To Laugh" video*
"Archive."
Yep.
"Anchovies."
"Arch-ive."
*laughter*
So one- one for the- one for the Tyler camp there.
I guess that's pretty good.
"Archive."
Yep.
"Arşiv."
*laughing* Oh no.
Oh, they're Turkish, okay, that's fine.
That's understandable,
if you're not a native English speaker,
that's fine.
"*dramatic music* *sighs*"
"Archive."
Okay, thank you RealLucasElliot.
"Arch-ive?"
"I don't know why that's important, but okay."
It was wrong! It was wrong!
I don't know why it's so funny to me, but
this is so funny, it's like when I was doing that Don't Laugh thing, and the guy was just saying
mispronunciations of the word "pregnant" over and over again, and for some reason in repetition,
it's fucking funny.
So, I picked out a word. I actually looked up- I looked up on the list of most difficult words
to pronounce. Okay, so send me a video of you saying the word "worcestershire".
I don't even know how to say that word. *spoilers: its wer-ster-sher. thank me later, Mark.*
"War-chester-shire!"
"Wer-sherster-sher!"
"Worsh-worsh-sherter!"
"War-sis-ter-shur-ey!"
"War-ses-ter-show-ra!"
Uh, "Worship satan!"
"Where is Sharon?"
"Wor- worry not sister shire!"
Uh, "Warts and shit!"
"Warts steer me wrong."
"Warts for hire."
Uh, "Rollercoasters."
What the fuck is this?
What the fuck is this?!
WHAT THE FUCK IS THIS?!
"Worst-er-shire."
*laughter*
"Worst-er-sh- no. Not doing it."
*laughing* Well that's mean.
"Wor-shshshshshshshshshsh-SSHAAAY-re sh-auce?"
*laughter*
*lip smack*
*laughter continues*
"Worsh-ter-shire?"
"Worst-er-sher."
"Yep."
"I got it right."
*laughter*
"Markiplier is the worst YouTuber." *Mark isn't Leafy, ok?"
That sounds about right.
That makes sense.
If you compare the two, if you put the words right next to each other,
I-I think that's correct.
"War-kes-ter-shire."
*laughter*
That was one of MY pronunciations.
"War-ker-shire?"
No.
No, that was wrong.
"War-shter-shter-shire. Subscribe!"
*laughter*
"War-ster-shire. *giggles*"
*loud muffled voice* "War-chester-shire."
What the fuck was that?! *it sounded like someone strangling a walrus in the background.*
*laughing* What the fuck?!
Media could not be played?!
Too late! I got it, poecop!
I got it!
"War-shen-sire?"
"I don't even- I can't even remember what it sa-"
*laughter*
"War-chester-shire."
"Worsh-ter-shire."
"Penis."
*11 full seconds of Mark laughing his ass off*
I am a twelve year old.
"War-chester-shire. Pew pew pew pew pew pew!"
*laughter*
I love the enthusiasm.
"You guys are idiots."
*laughing* Oh yeah, yeah, yeah, we are. Oh yeah, we are.
"War-chester-shur."
*Laugh gets cut off, sounds like a honk*
*laughing* "Shur?"
*with Spanish accent* "War-cester-shire-ey!"
It's probably close enough, well done!
Well done, that's good!
"War-cester- wer- wer-shen-shot- wer-ces-ter-shire- wer- oysters? I-" *sarah.exe has stopped responding, please press any key to continue*
*laughter*
"How about no, you fucking walnut?"
I've never been called a wall-not.
Or a walnut. Or either of those things.
But I appreciate the candor!
"It's pronounced wer-ster-sher, but you spelled it war-ses-ter-shire, so I don't know what you're on, Mark."
*Girl, Mark is high on life, not drugs*
Well, uh, it's-
What do you mean?! That's how I- that's how you spell it!
"War-chester-shire!"
I don't know any more.
It's "war-chester-shire".
What are you on about, adventureanalisa?!
*echoing* "War-chester-shire."
I felt that in the back of my neck.
Jesus.
"Worst-er-shire?"
"Worst-er-sh-"
*laughing* "Worst-er-sh-"
"Send nudes."
"Mark is a dingleberry. *laughs*"
*laughing* Well at least it made you laugh!
*clears throat*
*gross*
"Shut up."
*Markimoo wail*
"Pussy."
*laughing* What?!
*laughter*
"War-ses-ter-shire."
Nice effort there, Ysaaaaaa.
"If you're talking about the sauce, it's worsh-ter-shire sauce."
"Rat."
Uh-huh.
It's a city!
*warning headphone users... AGAIN*
RAAAAAAAAAAaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaa
aaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaat!
"Number one, it's 11pm. Number two, war-ses-..."
"The fuck is that? War-ses-shire?"
"Listen, you need to fucking go to bed, you fucking bitch."
*laughing* Okay, alright.
I take that as my cue to leave.
Yeah, but either way, it's just a really funny thing, 'cause
I- it- it was this- this, like, hilarious concept,
and- just because Tyler is so funny,
he's so funny in the way that he is.
It's like- it's just like, he is- he is funny because of how "Tyler" he is.
I didn't know if this was going to be funny, but then again, I don't know if it's actually funny because I laugh at pretty much anything.
But,
I had a good time,
so either way,
you know, I just wanted to-
I just wanted to experiment with this to see what the fuck was gonna happen with it, and
I-I just started giggling like a little bitch.
But anyway, there are a lot of things that I could do with this that have audience participation,
like, the point of this is, that it involves you guys in little simple things that just make people laugh for no good reason,
other than the fact that it's stupid.
But we're all collectively stupid, so it's funniness together!
Which is good too, so...
I hope you guys are having a wonderful new year so far,
I know it's only a week into it,
uh, and- but I really hope that you guys are sticking with whatever you guys have chosen as your new year's resolution,
and just remember what I said,
it really does not come down to motivation.
Motivation will leave you faster than you can imagine it'll be gone.
Like, it'll be gone a couple weeks in and you'll already be back to the same old ways.
It's about discipline,
and holding yourself accountable, and training yourself to be better, and expecting more out of yourself.
Putting the goals higher and higher, but incrementally higher.
Because it's day by day progress and that's the only way that you can actually be better.
So I hope you guys are doing it, and remember,
uh, we are going to be doing a charity livestream this month. We haven't decided on what or when, but be on the lookout for that.
Uh, it should be coming, more details very soon, so,
Thank you everybody so much for watching.
And as always, I will see you...
in the next video.
Buh-bye!